new research is bringing hope to women
with a hard-to-treat type of breast
cancer a study published over the
weekend in the New England Journal of
Medicine found that combining
chemotherapy with immunotherapy medicine
added up to 10 months of survival time
for patients with triple negative breast
cancer our dr. David agus leads us EES
Westside Cancer Center in California and
joins us this morning good morning this
is good news indeed so explain how this
immunotherapy worked so immuno therapy
when you give to a woman with breast
cancer and had marginal results didn't
do that much
in the past now when you combine it with
chemotherapy it unleashes the immune
system so the tumor cells are born with
it don't eat any signal or on the
surface and this drug blocks that don't
eat me signal you couple that with
killing some cells with chemotherapy and
those immune cells go crazy and this is
a 10 month survival advantage in this
subsection of women with triple negative
breast cancer which is one of the worst
kinds of breast cancer ten months
doesn't sound like a long time unless
you're the one that gets the extra 10
months but when I heard 10 months I
thought oh I wish it was longer but you
say 10 months is a big deal well you
know the average survival in this study
was 15 months and bringing that up to 25
months and what that means is we're
gonna get better at doing it also and
hopefully go beyond that I'm an optimist
10 months buys you 10 more months of
hope for new advances there's no
treatments which are literally coming
every few months to attack this disease
but this is a big one what is triple
negative breast cancer and how common is
it you always bring us back to earth
it's so reality breast cancer many of
the types have a particular singing
amount no I would kill the estrogen
receptor the progesterone receptor or
her - this is the catcher that has none
of them so it's about 15 to 20 percent
of breast cancers but it's about 40
percent of breast cancer deaths so
there's nothing to target so the outcome
is pretty more it's an aggressive
outcome with a poor outcome - the
patients with this type of breast cancer
but this changes it we've seen advances
and many of the types of breast cancer
and finally we're seeing one a triple
negative breast cancer and just remind
people what immunotherapy is and explain
can they get it right away so there are
drugs on the market with immunotherapy
now they've been fda-approved this
particular one for bladder cancer for
example they've been approved for lung
cancer for kidney cancer for melanoma
and so all of a sudden you have New
England
having a paper saying you can lift ten
months longer if you add this drug to
your therapy but it will take
significant time for the FDA to approve
this drug so if you're a patient the big
conundrum the big problem is you say
listen I want this treatment and yet I
can't afford to pay for it till the FDA
gives it a stamp my insurance company
said I'll pay for it so there is that
interval and that interval to me is
really tough and emotional because what
do you do you know there's a potential
benefit if who's gonna pay for that
people literally can't afford to worry
all right very encouraging news Thank
You dr. David good thank you and to see
him sitting at the table Thank You Gail